ich will nur reden reden reden
ich weiß nur ich habe gesagt ich finde
der film und den skate heißt will amis
moses oder auf englisch oder noch
englischer baby tief von sharon murphy
und das ist eine liebeskomödie über die
geschichte einer krebskranken jungen
frau und eines drogensüchtigen
obdachlosen und wer bei dieser
beschreibung bereits im home office sich
irgendwie unter dem schreibtisch
verkriechen will verpasst ein wahnsinnig
lustigen sehr ernsten waren sie nicht
traurigen unglaublich starken feld
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn mindestens zwei filme ein neues
genre ergeben dann gibt es offenbar
jetzt das genre des krebs mädchen liebes
teenager films und zwar gab es da 2014
schon die verfilmung von portimao stars
das schicksal ist ein visa verräter oder
in wiso einzigen titel hat das mit der
sagenhaften charleen white lady sowieso
zu den zehn besten damen auf der welt
gehört und einem unglaublich daneben und
eben deshalb sehr treffenden wilhelm
davor als der lieblingsschriftsteller
und da ging es eben auch um junge
menschen die den sensenmann fürchten
müssen und der sie dann auch erwischt
nur der unterschied jetzt zudem scheinen
murphy film über den wir reden ist das
in diesem film in dem 2014 film die
jugendlichen doch sehr vernünftig sind
also ist so die vorstellung von waisen
dem tod geweihten jugendlichen diese
erwachsene haben es ist uns sehr so
jugendbuch reger ton während bei
scheinen murphy jetzt diese junge müller
einfach komplett daneben ist wie sich
auch gehört und kaputt ist und dann aber
eben nicht nur kaputt ist und sich ein
freund suchte er auch kaputt ist der
aber auch nicht nur kaputt ist und es
ist ein viel stärkerer ensemblefilm das
ist ein film der das gewebe zwischen
menschen die am abgrund stehen viel
stärker macht der viel stärker sagt dass
das was eigentlich alle wichtigen
beziehungen ausmacht liebesbeziehungen
auch beruflichen beziehungen der vater
ist in psychiater und schon allein
deswegen komplett überfordert von der
situation aber auch
freundschaftsbeziehungen und ähnliche
geschichten dass das eben alles auf eine
art von freiwilligkeit beruht die durch
so eine grenze bei der man weiß okay wir
müssen irgendwann sterben extrem
intensiv werden kann im lustigen wie
gesagt der film hatten unfassbar gutes
komisches timing es gibt so viele szenen
die man nur verpassen würde wenn man sie
nach erzählen würde aber eben auch in so
eine art von tragik die mich so eitel
spreizt mit schwere und mit finsternis
und all dem quatsch sondern es ist so
bunt wie schreckliche sachen eben sind
wer noch nicht so unterhaltsam wie
donald trump oder so aber
der ist einfach zu teuer auf dauer
leiser scanlan die dem ila spielt war
selber zu dem zeitpunkt wo das gedreht
wurde 19
und bringt einem sehr nahe auf eine art
die nicht buschi ist die nicht des hin
schiebt sondern die ist einfach so hin
stellt und dann guckst du dadurch wie
durch so eine glasskulptur dass sie
keine zeit hat dass sie nicht möchte
dass die leute ihre zeit verschwenden
und es sagt sie dann irgendwann auch mal
diesem freudigen köder in den sie sich
dafür liebt er sie am anfang in
lebensgefahr bringt und von dem sie eben
irgendwann sagt das ist der tod wallace
ich hab dich am anfang toll gefunden
weil die vor nichts angst hast aber ich
glaube der grund dafür dass du vor
nichts angst was ist das ja alles
scheißegal ist und das bringt ja dann
wieder nicht und natürlich macht er dann
genau die transformation durch dass ihm
irgendwann alles nicht mehr scheißegal
ist oder nicht mehr alles scheißegal ist
und die lern halt aneinander was und
zwar ganz knapp also es ist nicht
irgendwie so der pädagogische bogen den
hollywood filme sonst servieren sondern
es ist so ein gerade noch die kurve
kriegen das auch hätte schiefgehen
können und dadurch umso kostbarer ist
[Musik]
dieser enorme emotionale impact in der
film hat also wir sind damals vor etwa
einem jahr in venedig als dann doch
schon ziemlich verbrauchte kritiker der
leaf glaube ich gar nicht so früh im
programm als leute die also das gar
nicht mehr so viele filme sehen müssen
um irgendwie genug zu haben davon da
raus gegangen und waren ziemlich fertig
und das schöne daran ist aber dass
dieser emotionale wusste in der film
packt nicht von haare raufen und
händeringend kommen sondern offenbar
tatsächlich mit einer großen kühle und
intelligenz auch ein bisschen am
reißbrett gemacht ist wo man sagt ich
bin stolz auf meine künstlerischen
mittel ich bin stolz als eine
regisseurin bin die timing kann ich bin
stolz solche regisseurin bindi weiß
welche szene ist lang welche szene ist
kurz was mache ich für zwischentitel was
mache ich mit musik das zum beispiel
golden brown von den stranglers sowieso
der beste pop song aller zeiten ist das
wusste man eigentlich aber wenn man ihn
dann mit streichern inszeniert kann er
plötzlich mit mozart mithalten dann
fällt mozart zurück dann holt mozart
wieder auf und solche autorennen
zwischen ästhetischen reiz momenten
machen diesen film halt wahnsinnig stark
im sinne von wie kann eigentlich
irgendwas das so klar mit dem kopf
komponiert ist und mit dem kopf
dirigiert ist eine musik sein die nicht
komplett zum heulen bringt wie in alten
schlosshund antworten halt gut ein
besonderes lob verdient beim ende
sondern weil er nämlich die
allerschlimmste rolle hat der hat
nämlich die rolle des vaters der im
grunde einfach gar nichts machen kannst
war keineswegs begründet erinnert dass
das das war keineswegs begründet durch
du kannst nicht kann es nicht kann nicht
kannst nicht kann es nicht jetzt schon
durch haben er guckt zu so er wird dann
am ende noch mal so was verpflichtet was
er machen soll wenn das unausweichliche
unausweichlicher weise passiert ist aber
in der tat wenn der film witz ist und
das ist ja auch neben einer tragödie und
zwar sehr gut erzählt er wissen willst
du wirklich sehr lustig ist dann ist
dieser vater eigentlich auf eine art
plante nämlich fallhöhe was kann man nur
tun antwort eigentlich kann man nichts
tun aber es geht eben beim menschen
nicht nur um zu tun es geht auch darum
wie man sich dazu verhält was für ein
gesicht man macht und ob man seine würde
auch dann waren kann wenn man in die
hose stopfen muss zu einem zeitpunkt wo
man dachte man es unbeobachtet oder so
und ben mendelsohn ist ja schon eine
weile dabei und wird gerne von steven
spielberg irgendwie als monster und
schurke verwendet und auch sonst so zu
sagen ist einfach eine verlässliche
größe und hier dafür wirklich dermaßen
am arsch sein auf eine würdige auf eine
männliche es gibt nämlich
und einfach all around einnehmende art
dass man denkt der ist auf einem kurs
den kann man auch noch mit 80 sehen aus
dem alten mann wird noch ich kann dich
nicht leiden
aber müller halte ich für etwas
besonderes und hier sollte die ganze
welt zu füßen legen